we've got to talk about healthcare today
great to be back from the fourth of July
holiday and during that holiday Donald
Trump pretty casually called for hey if
we can't pass something to replace the
Affordable Care Act with let's just
repeal Obamacare and figure out the rest
later which is effectively saying I'm
indifferent to 32 million people losing
their health insurance do not allow this
to be anything but a depraved and
outrageous suggestion from the president
Obamacare passed in 2010 real problems
with Obamacare including that it's
actually pretty damn conservative
anything that says hey here's tens of
millions of new customers for for-profit
insurance companies not exactly a
liberal panacea Republicans during
President Obama's presidency voted
dozens of times in the house to try to
repeal the Affordable Care Act of course
they knew or at least if they had any
connection to reality they should have
known there was no chance that they were
actually going to succeed in repealing
the Affordable Care Act Donald Trump ran
on repeal and replace the Affordable
Care Act and what we've seen so far
since January 20th of 2017 is the
American Health Care Act attempt number
one absolute and total disaster
estimated twenty four million people
were going to lose health coverage the
affordable of the American Health Care
Act attempt number two
the House version would have led to 23
million people losing their health
insurance the latest Senate version is
scored by the CBO the Congressional
Budget Office would have led to 22
million people losing their health
insurance Mitch McConnell last week
determined to get a vote before the July
4th recess didn't happen major failure
many Republicans not happy with the bill
and said no we're not on board with it
and as I said last week there are only
Republicans to blame for the fact that
they haven't passed something so far so
what does Donald Trump do over the
fourth of July weekend he tweets hey if
we can't figure out how to replace this
thing let's just repeal Obamacare and
figure out the rest later Donald Trump
tweeting on his Twitter account if
Republican senators are unable to pass
what they are working on
they should immediately repeal and then
replace at a later date this will lead
to 32 million people losing their
insurance . i don't need to qualify it i
don't need to say anything else about it
now where do i get the number 32 million
people let's put that on record just so
you don't think I'm making this up the
Congressional Budget Office did an
analysis one of those times that
Republicans floated the idea of merely
repealing the Affordable Care Act they
determined that 32 million people nearly
10 percent of our country's population
would lose coverage by 2026 19 million
of them would lose Medicaid coverage
people already die because they don't
have health care and way more people are
going to die from lack of care if
Obamacare is repealed and replaced with
the AHCA
even more people will die if you just
repeal Obamacare what do you have left
if you just repeal Obamacare
nothing well I think this strategy is a
sly way to get Democrats on board
because you can repeal Obamacare
probably with just the Republicans in
the House and the Senate you can appeal
to the people on the far right and not
really have to grab the moderates as
well and then when there's that interim
phase while Obamacare is phasing out
slowly then Democrats may be guilted
into joining on board and passing
something similar to what they have now
which is the American health care it's
possible but the timing of that has to
be so perfect for Republicans to not get
crushed in 2018 and or 2020 I mean
you're basically threading a needle
where you're saying we've got to start
causing just enough misery that
Democrats might agree to our terms but
not so much that Republican voters hold
us accountable so it's certainly
possible but it would require such
incredible timing to do that and I
cannot possibly overstate the perversion
and the moral corruption of the
suggestion particularly from the guy who
campaigned on creating a quote beautiful
replacement to Obamacare that was going
to work for everyone
less money no one uninsured better care
the suggestion now is just get rid of
Obamacare period
the way things are going there might
never be a replacement especially if you
get Obamacare out of the way first and
then Republicans Pat might say let's
just blame Democrats for what's going on
because hey Obamacare was bad and we
repealed it and that was our campaign
promise and we did it the fact that we
haven't passed anything else let's just
blame that on Democrats even though
again it's Republicans that are
preventing them from passing it so far
well I think taking the coverage from 32
million people without any replacement
option would play terribly for
Republicans right and there's no chance
that would be able to hold the house in
2018 if they did that I hope that might
be good for Democrats but we don't sit
here and say well that would be good
overall politically for us so just screw
the people off their health insurance as
the right is doing not only that I
talked about the reversible or the
meaningless actions that Donald Trump
has taken firing certain departments
from the White House people resigning
whatever we've talked about that some of
the meaningless symbolic executive
orders we've talked about that this
would not be one of them right to the
extent that Donald Trump is supportive
of Republicans in the House and Senate
saying just a straight-up repeal of
Obamacare that would not be one of the
reversible actions of Donald Trump and
Republicans if you care about net
neutrality consider this an attack on
net neutrality because if you're sick
and you've got no health care that
becomes your priority not activating
around net neutrality if you care about
education consider this suggestion from
Donald Trump and attack on education
because if you're sick and have no
health care it's hard to be working on
education if you care about the
environment consider this suggestion and
attack on the environment because if
you're sick and have no health care that
is your priority day to day not the
environment these are straight-up liars
Democrats and Republicans are the same
on many issues and when they are I call
them out for it not here not this one
they said the Republicans said this
isn't about political points from just
repealing Obamacare we want to replace
Obamacare with something that works for
everyone
then why is anyone talking about a
straight repeal as a possible good idea
it is discussed
do not allow this to be normalized and
by the way who is my representative calm
whether you're a Democrat or a
Republican
whether you're represented by a Democrat
or a Republican this is an issue where
you have to make your voice heard and
we're going to be covering this until we
have some kind of resolution on it